الى تفاصيل سنبداها من تطورات الحرب في
اوكرانيا والتي دخلت عامها الثاني قبل
يومين حيث شن رئيس روسيا
جديدا على الغرب متهما اياه بمحاوله تصفيه
بلاده واشار بوتين الى ان الغرب يريد
تصفيه روسيا وتقسيمها الى دويلات يسهل
السيطره او يسهل السيطره عليها بوتين تهم
الغرب وذراعه حلف الناتو بانه شريك غير
مباشر في جرائم ارتكبتها اوكرانيا من خلال
الاصرار على ارسال الاسلحه فيما يشدد
بوتين على ضروره ان تاخذ موسكو في
الاعتبار القدرات النوويه لحلف الناتو
واعلن بوتين ان بلاده لا تعارض مشاركه دول
الناتو في مناقشه وبحث معاهده نيو ستارت
النوويه التي اعلنت موسكو مؤخرا تعليقا
للعمل بها مشددا على ضروره وضع القدرات
النوويه لفرنسا وبريطانيا تحت الرقابه في
اي اتفاق مستقبل في هذه الاثناء قال وزير
الدفاع الروسي قال ان المدى الذي ستضطر
معه روسيا الى الدفاع عن حدودها ستحدده
شحنات الاسلحه الغربيه التي يتم توريدها
الى اوكرانيا واضاف شيجو ان روسيا لن
تتراجع عن تنفيذ اهدافها من العمليات
العسكريه في اوكرانيا لحمايه حدود البلاد
من اي تهديده
في غضون ذلك دفعت موسكو عن تعليق مشاركتها
في معاهده نيو ستارت النوويه وقال رئيس
جهاز الاستخبارات الخارجيه الروسيه
قال ان القرار كان بمثابه مفاجاه للغرب
لكنه اكد انه كان منطقيا
متابع هذا الموضوع مع زمينا من موسكو
مراسله العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد عبد
الجواد اهلا بك معنا اولا تصريحات بوتين
في اي اطار نضعها هل هي مقابله وهل تسرب
شيء اخر عما قال بخصوص هجومه عن الغرب
او على الغرب
مرحبا نعم ريم مرحبا نعم بالفعل يعني
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين خرج اليوم
للحديث عن الاستراتيجيه وعن السلاح
الاستراتيجي في العالم من قبل موسكو من
جهه ومن قبل الجانب الغربي من من جهه اخرى
بوتين طبعا في بدايه حديثه تحدث عن ضروره
التقييم الصحيح لموسكو للوضع ووضع السلاح
النووي الاستراتيجي لدى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولد حلف الناتو هي رسائل طبعا
تحدث بها بوتين لكن لابد من لفت الانتباه
بان خطاب بوتين دوما هو صريح يعني والشعب
والمجتمع الروسي متعود على تقبل كلماته
كما يقولها لذلك طبعا الخطاب كما قرئ
سياسيا في البلاد كما سمعه الشارع الروسي
يتحدث عن ان موسكو تمد يدها لطاوله الحوار
من جديد لكن مع الابقاء على يعني قوه
الرضع في حال تعرض الداخل الروسي او تعرضت
روسيه لضربات او تم يعني تزويد نظام كييف
باسلحه بعيده المدى او مقاتلات يمكنها
الوصول نحو مناطق روسيه في الداخل او شبه
جزيره القرن يعني الموضوع طبعا هو
المره الاولى التي
ليست يتحدث فيها بهذه الطريقه عن الغرب
ولكن كانت له كذلك تصريحات اخرى وهنا
الجديد في الموضوع بوتين فتح امكانيه ان
يشارك الناتو في مناقشه نيو ستارت بعد ان
علقت روسيا او على الاقل انسحبت منها
مؤخرا هذا ما قالته روسيا الرسميه كيف
تعاملت وكيف تفاعلت الاوساط السياسيه
الروسيه مع هذا التصريح
يعني هذا التصريح يدل ريم حول الاوساط
الاوساط السياسيه في البلاد يعني يتحدث
حول ان موسكو في حال رغبت بمناقشه القوه
النوويه الغربيه لابد لها من حسابات ما
تملكه لندن وما تملكه باريس وما يملكه حلف
الناتو بشكل كلي طبعا لا يخفى على احد بان
فرنسا وبريطانيا وحدها تملك قرابه 600
طبعا صاروخ استراتيجي لذلك طبعا لا بد من
الاخذ بعين الاعتبار هذا الحجم الكبير
طبعا الاتفاق بين موسكو واشنطن بما يخص
بما يخص هو معروف وجميع بنوده متاحه
للجميع لكن طبعا لم يؤخذ فيها حساب ما
يملكه لذلك طبعا موسكو تتحدث اليوم من
جديد عن ضروره معرفه وحساب القدرات
الغربيه في هذا الموضوع لذلك طبعا موسكو
علقت العمل في اتفاقيه ستارت طبعا لا يخفى
على احد بان دخول العامل الصيني على
المواجهه وعلى طرح الفكره التي قد توصل
بالجميع الى طاوله الحوار يلعب دورا
محوريا بهذا الموضوع هي مرحله لعدد
الاصابع يراها البعض ريم لرفع سقف
المطالبات على ما يبدو ان الزياره الصينيه
الاخيره لموسكو قد يتبعها زيارات صينيه
الى الى
عقد لقاءات مع الرئيس الاوكراني
مع الجانب الصيني قد تثمر عبر حوار لكن
النقطه الاساسيه التي اجتمع عليها
المحللون السياسيون اليوم في البلاد
والقراءه العسكريه بانه حتى هذه اللحظه
كيف قرارها ليس مستقل وهي عباره عن قطعه
على لوحه الشطرنج الكبيره التي يلعب بها
الغرب هذا ما تحدث عنه السياسيون في
البلاد اليوم سيبقى موضوعا للمتابعه شكرا
جزيلا لك عبد الجواد الرشد مراسل العربيه
من موسكو